no you're not building fortresses and
defending them for monsters but I assure
you this is fortnight hot on the heels
of player unknowns battlegrounds Epic
Games released a battle royale mode
which throws some of what's unique about
fortnight into a game that's very
similar to pub G of course Blue Hole
didn't take too kindly to this
especially since epic games is the
company that licences pub G's Engine
Blue Hole even went as far to release a
statement that displayed it's obvious
disapproval and announced that it's
considering further action the thing is
punk G isn't the first Battle Royale
game sure Brendon player unknown Green
played a huge role in the modes
inception in popularity with mods for
ARMA 3 and h1z1 but since then there
have been several standalone Battle
Royale games and mods for other games
including minecraft on top of all this
the entire idea started with a Japanese
novel called battle royale which was
published in English in 2003 so the
question that comes to mind is can Blue
Hole really be successful in taking
action against epic games unfortunately
neither Blue Hole nor epic accepted my
request to talk about this so I brought
back video game attorney Ryan Morrison
to explain the situation to me and
perhaps unsurprisingly he says that you
can't own an idea genre or even a
mechanic in most cases so you cannot own
an idea you can't own a genre you can't
even really own a mechanic outside of
some basic patents that exists in games
and could exist in the future but
generally you don't own those three
things so that's why we see a lot of
games that are similar if you could own
a genre or own an idea then the very
first first-person shooter would make it
so no one else can make one of those so
a battle royale type game which is based
on a movie that's not even originally
theorized hype by Blue Hole is never
gonna be a protective thing there are
assets of course that are copyrightable
and protectable there's trademark
elements that are protectable and
copyrightable and there's a lot of stuff
here that I think Blue Hole is right to
be upset about but the overall genre or
idea that they're claiming to own is a
step too far in my opinion and
unfortunately for Blue Hole there was a
bit of a backlash to its initial
statement there have been plenty of
people confused and angered by Blue Hole
seemingly asserting that it owns the
Battle Royale idea that statement even
says pub G is the first standalone
Battle Royale game when titles like h1z1
king of the kill and the culling
launched in 2016
Morrison told me that Blue Hole probably
thought the internet would side with it
and quote light epic games on fire Blue
Hole has since clarified to PC gamer
that its specific problem is with the
fact that the company which developed
fortnight battle royale is also the
licensure of pub G's engine but Morrison
told me that doesn't complicate anything
legally however it is a question of
ethics Morrison says that blue hole
works directly with epic to make sure
that their game can be supported by
Unreal Engine 4 so the fact that epic
then went on to create a direct
competitor seems a little unethical but
it's also legal and Morrison says that
blue hulls public statement edged
closely to biting the hand that feeds
them of course
epic wouldn't actually stop doing
business with Blue Hole because that
would just make matters worse and in
regards the Blue Hole statement there's
one thing Morrison specifically wanted
to talk about it's the phrase
considering further action which he says
doesn't actually have to mean anything
that's something I've put in every
cease-and-desist I've ever sent out
that's what lawyers say that's what
legal teams say that's what lawyers
allow their clients to say because
there's a big difference between saying
we're going to consider further action
versus we're going to do further action
if I say answer this by Thursday or I'm
suing you I need to sue you on Thursday
if you don't answer if I say answer this
by Thursday we will consider further
legal action then I don't really have to
do anything I'm considering it I'm not
putting myself in a hole I'm allowing
the the room for more negotiation for
figuring this out for other kind of
settlements and that's what blue hole
did here however none of this
necessarily means Epic Games is in the
clear one thing the fortnight's studio
did that definitely didn't seem on the
level was mentioning pub G and marketing
materials Morrison assured me that it's
legal to compare your game to another
but blue who could use it against them
in courts
Morrison doesn't think a suit is very
likely and believes that it wouldn't be
a winning situation for blue home but
it's stuff like this that the studio
could bring up and attempt to make a
case out of it shows a judge that epic
might be trying to ride pub G's
hills and that isn't necessarily a good
start for epics defense the most
contentious part of this at least to me
is the fact that epic beat blue hole two
consoles with a free-to-play option
Morrison says that this is something
that might actually push blue hole to
file a lawsuit or try for a
court-ordered injunction
I think being first to market in this
sense it is well it's an overall concept
legally first so it's the first person
to sell a copy anywhere on anything that
is now protected on everything
everywhere but what's interesting here
is that kind of first to market race
that that fortnight seemingly is gonna
win might make blue hole actually pull
the trigger on a lawsuit or try to get
some kind of injunction again I don't
think it's going to be successful but
it's not frivolous either there is
certainly arguments to be made here
there is a game that has admitted it is
a derivative work of ours which again I
don't agree with but by their
advertising and by their similarities
there is an argument to be made there
and I think blue hole would say listen
this work is a derivative work of ours
it's infringing on our game and it needs
to be stopped before it's allowed to go
to market on these consoles and it
should be taken down off the computer
that's what an injunction is basically
these guys aren't okay with what they're
doing so they have to stop and the court
orders them to stop stop selling it stop
downloading it all of the above and
that's what blue hole would attempt to
do here despite all these ifs codes and
mites Morrison stress that this is much
more likely to be settled outside of a
courtroom blue hole and epic might not
be talking to the public about any of
this but the two companies are
definitely talking to each other in fact
we might never hear of this particular
situation again and while it's likely
we'll see more battle royale games that
are trying to ride the pub G wave it
would be surprising if Blue Hole
responded to them in the same way that
it did with fortnight and in the end I
welcome more battle royale games
competition is an incredibly important
thing it pushes people to do better
and while pub G is already an excellent
experience it could always be improved
on from the get-go for tonight's battle
royale mode looks like a simple pub G
clone but it actually does some
interesting things around building and
setting traps it definitely doesn't feel
as satisfying or rewarding when you take
down an enemy but who knows maybe
another game can come along and do
battle royale better than pub G that's
the great thing about being able to
compete over the same idea absolutely
anyone
Bitto shots
you